all right take a look at jake garrieta's
talking about the struggles this is his
20th start of the season that era is
very high 6 34. and he's been getting
hit harder than he has ever in his
career that's lugging percentage and obs
off the charts told wong ready to go
here here comes the 1-0 swing line drive
base hit down the left field line for
wong good start for the brewers long a
big turn around first he's digging for
two here's the throw from hap it's not
going to be in time it's a lead-off
double for colton wong yell it's
in the middle of an 0 for 20 slump at
the plate and wong at second base and
yelich muscles one that's fair down the
line it goes wong will turn and head
home throw goes to second and christian
yellets with a base hit in an rbi and
the brewers strike first tonight in
wrigley
pulls that one on the ground through for
a base hit boy the brewers are finding
the holes early three consecutive hits
to start the game
adamus's hitting ways continue the claws
are up in the first
two on nobody out
second and third one away infield in for
the cubs and omar narvaez at the plate
and that's a bullet through for a base
hit yelich is in to score and it's
mishandled in right field and right
behind yelich's adamus
so the brewers put three on the board
here
omar narvaez with a base head then an
error by the right fielder dykman
at third base
in on the hands and
garcia hit by a pitch
remember last night had a very similar
thing
i mean almost identical to
what happened last night and remember
sophia reporting
she spoke to him that he lost feeling i
think they're going to take him out
question is was it a striker now was it
a swinging strike i think it might be so
tyrone taylor is coming on
and he's got a bat in his hand so that
would tell you that was
called a swinging strike been getting
regular at bats here lately and he
shoots one to right field to base in
galvaya is around third he'll score
easily
tyrone taylor steps in for garcia
delivers an rbi single and the brewers
lead four to nothing in the first
[Applause]
that's fair
inside the bag at third taylor is going
to come around to score
they are going to wave to les
he will score and lorenzo kane drives in
a pair
how about this start
six nothing milwaukee in the first
inning
wong the man who started all of this
with a lead off double down the left
field line
for the cubs that ball's hit sharply
that's going to get down it's another
hit and another runners in
kane will score seven to nothing brewers
wong into second base the brewers have
scored a touchdown here in the top of
the first against jake arrieta corbin
burns has a seven run lead before he
even toes the rubber
and now we'll see if burns can keep it
rolling here tonight
on the first pitch got a chance to turn
two adamus over to first there you go
and a 4-6-3 double play
the right-handed banner hits the ground
ball to third duffy grabs it steps on
third throws to first that's gonna be a
double play
tyrone taylor wraps into a 5-3 double
play
no runs from milwaukee we go to the
bottom of ending number two brewers
seven comes nothing like that just ended
schwendel swings and misses at a
breaking ball
and that's the first strikeout for
corbin burns o2 pitch
struck him out blocked by narvaez he'll
have to pick it up and fire to first in
time to get duffy on the strikeout
one-two pitch
and he struck him out he strikes out the
side here in the second as corbin burns
you can see the wind starting to kick up
a swing adam is he got him with a slider
four straight strikeouts for corbin
burns
tonight he's seeing a lot that's a swing
and a miss got him on a cutter
so add a fourth pitch
that he has
racked up mckay with he's got five k's
got him how about corbin burns six
consecutive strikeouts
he is dialed in in wrigley field
you work it out let me know 2-2 pitch
and he hooks one that is a fair ball and
past the diving schwendel
a base head for escobar yelich had to
hold up on the line drive
as narvaez turns one around into right
center field gonna be caught by ortega
yellets will tag and score
sac fly and an rbi and the brewers have
an eight to nothing lead
2-2 pitch swinging a mess he strikes out
ortega and that's the seventh straight
strikeout for corbin burns
that is a new career high for corbin
due to pitch and it is eight straight
strikeouts for corbin burns that is a
new franchise record
2-2 pitch and a swing at a miss it is
nine in a row
the strikeout string continues
how about this the brewers lead this
game eight to nothing
strike away got a chance at 10 in a row
o2 pitch and a swing at a miss there it
is
corbin burns ties a major league record
for consecutive strikeouts
10 in a row
dave that baseball here is matt duffy
swings to the first pitch in a base hit
so that'll stop the streak
but corbin burns
has put his name in the record books
comes batters are just over matt
[Applause]
driving the right hit well taylor makes
the catch crashes up against the wall
heck of a play by tyrone taylor
that ball kept on carrying but tyrone
taylor right place right time perfect
reach
and corbin burns gets the out
tyrone taylor a great catch right up
against the ivy and that brewer's
bullpen in right field
0-2
and a
cold strike three down he goes burns
with strikeout number 15
and no walks and he's got that record
too how about eight shutout innings
four hits
for corbin burns
[Applause]
and on the first pitch a pop-up wind is
blowing not easy
it's going to be taylor who makes a
catch and that'll end the ball game and
what a game it was
historic knighted wrigley for the
milwaukee brewers
they shut out the cubs 10 to nothing
corbin burns
matches a major league record for
consecutive strikeouts
and the brewers win their third
consecutive game in this series and they
make it eight straight against the
chicago cubs